[Applause]
[Music]
coming to you from los
angeles california this is ea
play live 2021 i'm your host
wwe superstar xavier woods aka austin
creed
and we have an amazing show for you
today we've got world premiere gameplay
exclusive first looks including a brand
new multiplayer experience for
battlefield 2042
and a few more surprises they won't even
let me tease
plus just like last year we've got some
amazing prizes to give away
so keep an eye out throughout the show
for hidden letters they'll spell out a
secret code that you'll need at the end
of the show
if you want a chance to win polaris gear
logitech gadgets and thousands of codes
for great ea games including
mass effect legendary edition dirt 5 and
more so let's get to it
ea has long played home to fan favorite
racing titles from
need for speed to burnout to real racing
and now that the experts at codemasters
are joining the ea family
that incredible lineup just got
supercharged with the addition of
franchises like grid
dirt project cars and f1 so if you like
racing
if you like being in the driver's seat
you're gonna love
what code masters has cooked up for us
today but first
let's take a quick look at what they do
[Applause]
[Applause]
best
[Music]
big
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'll find my oh from the bottom
[Applause]
[Music]
joining us now from london is
codemasters senior game designer
becky crossdale welcome becky hey austin
hey now i heard that you might have a
little surprise for us today
yes i do and i don't know if you can
tell austin but i am so excited
because on behalf of the entire code
masters team
this is the world premiere trailer for
grid legends
160 take 13 13.
dozens of drivers only one can become
champions
my name is yuna tanaka my goal is to
become the first woman ever
to win the championship they know who i
am
i'm nathan mccain five-time grid series
world champion
it seemed to be six times and that's a
new record
if it's grid legal i can build it to win
touring cars muscle cars open wheel
drift best team
best car win by having the money
by having the guts and if these idiots
can keep their cars on the track
[Applause]
[Music]
bring it on baby that's why we're here
becky this this looks incredible on top
of the gameplay in the cars and the
environments now
we've got all these characters that seem
to have different motivations i'm
already incredibly invested
it looks like you guys are really up in
the ante on storytelling well
first and foremost the grid series has
always been about delivering gameplay
excellence
and with grid legends you are still
getting that same immersive racing
experience that you know
and love but this time we are taking
things up a notch
and we're adding another layer on top of
that we are really proud of this new
story mode
well i do love a good story and i feel
like i've seen a lot of those faces
somewhere before
yet we had the absolute pleasure of
working with the incredibly talented
shitty gagwa
who plays the wonderful eric in
netflix's sex education
we also captured the entire thing using
extended reality or
xr where if you've been watching
disney's and mandalorian you will have
seen that tech in action it's what they
used to create those incredible worlds
well it sounds amazing but this
obviously isn't racing in space right
no we are using this tech to draw you
further
into this racing experience we really
want to bring you
deeper into the grid world than ever
before
it's also been really great for our
actors because they're acting against
something that's visually there
it's not the same as green screen or
motion capture
they are stepping into our grid world
and reacting with it
it sounds great can you give us any
hints on the story or would that be
spoilers
without any spoilers um we are giving
you a classic
underdog tale we were putting you
straight into the driver's seat
right in the middle of the grid world
series where you'll be facing
off against the all dominant raven west
team
that is a team that does not like to
share the tarmac
and for the rest of the story well you
just have to wait and see
but let's talk gameplay uh we saw a new
big range of vehicles in that trailer
can you talk about those a little bit
oh yeah there are so many vehicles we
are giving you big rigs stadium trucks
drift cars
open wheelers muscle cars electric cars
we are giving you hyper cars like the
aston martin
valkyrie have you seen that car
and we are also giving you multi-class
mixed racing
which means that you can take any of
those cars and put them together on the
same track
whoa i just saw a big rig take out an
open wheeler in the trailer and i i love
it
so is there anything else that you can
tell us about grid legends
we are giving too much away there is
a ton of new stuff for the fans to sink
their teeth into
including some new modes such as boost
mode and elimination mode
we've also got some fancy new locations
like the
iconic city of moscow we've also got
the beautiful city of london as well as
you can drive right past buckingham
palace
or you could travel to the stunning
estrada alpena and take one of our
beautiful hypercars
to its limit all right well you heard it
here first
storytelling and extended reality mixed
class racing new modes new locations
this is beyond exciting so becky thank
you so much for your time
no thank you austin of course all right
folks
so we're just getting started we've seen
grid legends
and now it's time for a different breed
of legend
two years ago apex legends came out of
nowhere and now 100 million players and
17 legends later it just
keeps getting bigger we've got more
modes more maps more platforms for play
and of course more legends
so what's next for apex well today
we have answers ladies and gentlemen i
give to you apex legends emergence
change i see it in everything
i see it in a boy rocked by tragedy
transform his pain and defy reality
i see it in the warrior who must choose
between their new life
and the annihilation of their home
i see it in a girl tortured by revenge
embrace hope when love awakens her heart
i see it in me a boy born under a bad
woman
turn his tail
into a legend
change is relentless
but that does not mean it cannot be
beautiful
[Music]
and take comfort
[Music]
nothing lasts forever
[Music]
you must adapt
surrender
and embrace your true nature
know that you are not alone
change comes for us all
[Applause]
but this chaos has purpose
all of us thrown together
[Music]
so the flame can burn its brightest
change fight it
and fall
accept it and rise above
wow i'm standing here like slack-jawed
watching this
because there's so much to unpack from
that trailer so let's go ahead and meet
the man with
all the answers apex game director chad
grenier
so happy to have you here chad thanks
austin happy to be here uh before we get
started and get into it i want to give a
shout out to the amazing developers at
respawn
hey all right well a subset of them uh
if you love apex it's because of these
amazing developers that are
working hard to creating apex legends
for us
well big love to the whole respawn team
especially whoever came up with lifeline
cause that's
my girl but okay there's a lot for us to
talk about but you know i'm geeked about
seer so can you tell us some more about
his abilities
i saw this man stare through walls he's
got drones coming out of his chest
please tell me about his kit yeah
similar to bloodhound
seer is all about tracking enemies but
in a different way and has a very unique
kit
so while you're aiming down the sights
you'll have a heartbeat sensor that will
give you hints as to
where an enemy might be if you think
you've located them you can use your
tactical
which sends out some of those drones out
of your chest and will
actually reveal and track the enemy's
location the ultimate is really powerful
especially in certain gameplay
situations you can send out hundreds of
micro drones
and create a sphere around an area that
you choose and
all enemies that are moving quickly to
that space are tracked
i love when there's new abilities that
kind of change the game
because this game obviously is always
changing always evolving and whenever
there's a new legend
there's always an interesting shift in
the meta so with those incredible
abilities how do you think that sears
going to change the game
yeah again i mentioned bloodhound also
as a tracker
but unlike bloodhound seer is about very
precise and lingering information
so he's a bit more of a stealth oriented
legend and you're going to see i think
some interactions because of that sphere
i mentioned his ultimate
if you're moving quickly through that
space your footsteps are revealed
but now if you're walking slowly you can
avoid the the detection
and so i think you'll see some
interesting gameplay experiences and new
ways to play
yeah with slowing it down a bit yeah it
sounds like once the ring gets tight
especially
you're gonna have a lot of new ways to
play this game
um but this past season for instance it
felt like apex really moved beyond
battle royale with the introduction of
arenas so what's the reaction been like
for you guys the fan reaction has been
really great we've seen a lot of players
enjoy arenas which is which is awesome
we're really excited to finally have a
way to play apex legends beyond battle
royale
and yeah people are loving it so we've
got new maps in the works
and some other things come in i don't
want to you know talk about just yet
but we've got a lot planned for arenas
all right fair fair well
i do know that you guys announced ranked
arenas are coming as well so can you
give us some information on that
yep so we've got one season of arenas
under our belts now
we wanted to make sure that we were
seeing how players were adapting to the
mode
make sure to get the balance right make
sure that the the price and the economy
is correct
and now we'll be introducing the ranked
mode in emergence so it's a bit of a
different
ranked system than we have in in the
battle royale mode so we're really
excited for you to get your hands on it
well
it's really cool to see apex always
doing new things like for instance
uh leaning into the competitive scene
with things like the apex legends global
series so are we gonna see
more of the algs absolutely we just
ended year one of algs our championships
recently
concluded and it was amazing there's
like so many tactics and
amazing plays in there many teams were
fighting for the championship in the
last round we hit record numbers
so we're really excited in september to
be kicking off year two of the lgs
and for the first time we're going to be
inviting playstation
and xbox players to compete alongside
the pc players really see who's best and
an all new league format so
um we have more information at
playapex.com
algs well i am beyond looking forward to
it and
chad before you go i have to ask
when can we see more from seer we've got
an awesome
gameplay trailer coming on monday and
emergence drops on august 3rd
and for now i can show you a finisher of
course please
please
this game demands so much of us
but from you she demands
everything that that's that's all i need
to see
it's just it's so awesome but chad thank
you so much for being here thanks austin
of course of course
and again big shout out to the whole
respawn team
now for the apex fans watching us on
twitch today respawn is hooking you up
with an exclusive
jump master gun charm so make sure
you've got your twitch
and ea account linked and keep watching
the show to earn that drop
but that's not the only thing we're
given out today
keep an eye out for the hidden letters
that spell out a secret phrase because
at the
end of the show we'll give you a link
where you can enter that code for your
chance to win some great prizes
including codes
for ea originals like knockout city and
it takes two
so speaking of originals let's head
across the ocean for some stop motion
and check out a soon-to-be-released ea
original
lost in random
and just like that young austin found
himself
introducing a new segment hello
he stored bewildered by the voice coming
from somewhere unknown somewhere
random uh okay
all right anyway uh it's coming soon and
it looks
really cool austin stopped himself i had
forgotten to mention
the tribeca film festival selection it
was a
selection at the tribeca film festival
he tried the line again more
enthusiastically look man i'm trying to
run a whole show
or enthusiastically really selling it
could you just let me intro the segment
thank you i am
it was an official tribeca film festival
selection this summer and it's coming
soon
joining us from gothenburg sweden to
tell us more is zoink creative director
olav redmon
hello austin how's it going olaf thank
you so much for joining us and
congratulations on tribeca
it's so cool to see video games right
next to movies being regarded as they
should be
thank you austin i'm so proud of the
song team and what we've accomplished
and
i'm so happy about this election because
lost in random is really inspired by all
these
movies that i grew up with and stop
motion animation and dark fairy tales
and
and at sonic we're always trying to push
narrative in video games so
i'm so happy yeah well i i can't wait to
see more oh love of my life
what do you have for us today i'm super
pleased to share a first look at one of
our most
unique aspects of lost venom's gameplay
dice battle which is an exciting
explosive blend of real time action and
time stop tactics
where every roll of the dice unleashes
incredible powers out of the head
of your jack-in-the-box buddy dicey well
it
sounds awesome so let's take a look
once upon a time there were two devoted
sisters
named even and ord
cruelly separated by an evil queen
and the roll of a dice
together with this little fella
even was determined to rescue her
beloved sister
[Music]
come on dicey
in this strange and fascinating world of
random
adventure and combat go hand in hand
and many peculiar characters await
some will help you mean
this one and some won't that's against
the rules
[Music]
oh sure a little girl with a dice
those coins can be traded for cards
frogs i got cards here
the greatest cards in the land
cards contain new attacks abilities
and more all of which
come in handy during dice battle
ready even uses her slingshot to attack
deadly foes this can knock off energy
cubes
used to feed the strange companion dicey
and once fully charged even can
i see and freeze time itself
let's see how she uses it
impressive
[Music]
well done even nice
that was a good one
even's quest will take her across all
six realms of random
even must roll the dice and play the
odds
[Music]
but just a chance at saving her sister
random rooms long macy rage
[Music]
just from that alone i already
need to play this game it looks so cool
uh but what can you tell me about these
these combat cards that we're seeing
cars are just one part of dice battle
but i love the way they look so i
brought a few examples to show off
oh okay awesome what are we looking at
here then so as you saw cards can be
selected during combat that unleash new
powers and abilities like this one for
instance
explosive dice which turns dicey into
this ticking time bomb
but you just gotta be careful so it
doesn't blow you up keep your distance
and where's this hammer of two lets you
summon a giant hammer
which also gives even super strength to
be able to swing it around
offensive maneuvers i like it but it's
not just about orphans like we have also
for instance uma's blessing which comes
from uma this
old hidden witch and she provides a
bubble shield to protect even
and that's just a taste like there's a
lot of different powers at your disposal
some curse enemies
some heal even or create traps some
marinas also work as giant board games
affected by rolling dicey so you're
gonna have to try different tactics to
conquer the queen's giant
mad tabletop themed arenas all right
olav obviously
my next question you know it's coming
when can we play this game
yeah my favorite question lost in random
releases on september 10th on pc console
and nintendo switch and you can
pre-order starting right after the shows
and if you want a dicey companion of
your own he'll be available to ea play
members as a gun charm in one of my
current favorites
apex so keep an eye out for that well
you all heard it here first
and olav thank you so much for joining
us today it has been my absolute
pleasure austin
and welcome to random thanks well
there you have it lost in random is
coming soon but there's another ea
original that's already here
and it's bringing that throwback
playground heat to the masses
that's right i'm talking about knock out
city oh oh oh okay
dropped earlier this year knockout city
has had one hell of a summer and they're
just getting warmed up
here with more is karthik bala from
velen studios in new york
thanks austin we're so grateful to our
community for the massive response to
knockout city
with millions of new brawlers hundreds
of thousands of crews
and nearly a billion kos landed your
response has really been
a knockout as an indie team dedicated to
taking creative risks
having all of you embrace this unique
thing we've made
is an amazing feeling and i just want to
say
thank you at launch we promised you new
features and updates
that keep the game fresh and exciting
today
i'm here to deliver on that promise on
behalf of the whole velen studios team
it's my absolute thrill to present
knockout city
season two fight at the movies
in a world of chaos where
mayhem rules the streets is anyone
strong enough
to stop the unstoppable
a world where one hero rises to meet
instant regret
a world where lovers chase their
passions
and feel the burn
a world where terror lurks high above
where warriors fight for dodge brawl
supremacy
and teensy tiny brawlers battle it out
in a child's bedroom
this season bring your moves to the
movies
coming july
oh man that voice is murder on the pipes
the hollywood driving opens july 27th
we'll see you at the movies it's
showtime
[Music]
you saw it we got new skins we got a new
ball knockout city baby
season two arrives july 27th and
remember you can play for free
up to street rank 25 so get in you might
come across me and my crew we're called
that baseline you won't beat us because
we're really good
but you'll have fun and right now it's
available on
all platforms with cross play so if you
haven't yet go ahead get in there and
give it a whirl
all right everyone the moment that you
have been waiting for
is
ah here seen the trailers you've read
the hot takes and you already know that
battlefield is
back baby you hear me it's back
battlefield is back man it's a
battlefield
i can't wait to wingsuit surfer tornado
this game is gonna be so good
and in just a moment we're revealing a
brand new battlefield 20
42 experience but first for those who
haven't been paying attention
here's what you've been missing out on
that's the coolest thing i've ever seen
this is awesome do it
on behalf of our entire team we hope
you're thrilled with what you've seen so
far from battlefield 2042
but this is just the beginning we have
so
much more to show you battlefield 2042
is built up by three epic experiences
firstly of course all that warfare that
we showed you earlier
secondly hazard zone that will show off
later this year
and now a new community driven
experience that we're happy to share
with you today
built by our old friends over at triple
effect
formerly die slay it's an experience
designed from community feedback it's an
experience we've dreamt about building
for over a decade
so let's have a look
[Music]
[Music]
gotta step it up boys
[Music]
day
that's the sound of the
[Music]
that's the drone of them going
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
back
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
launcher
[Music]
is
this looks incredible there's so many
crazy things happening in this trailer
we got knives versus defibrillators we
got soldiers from every air i have
so many questions so let's bring on an
expert here to help us out is the
general manager of ripple effect we've
got
christian grass welcome christian hey
austin thanks for having me super
excited to be here
of course thank you for being here now
that trailer absolutely
ridiculous like what the hell did we
just see so what you just saw was the
battlefield portal it's a new community
driven experience that gives players the
freedom
to write their own rules and shape their
own battlefield
you can mix and match content from
battlefield 1942
that company 2 bf3 and battlefield 2042
to create brand new game modes then you
can share and discover those on the
portal platform
and that's just what's coming at launch
this is a real love letter to the fans
from our incredible team and oh oh and
this is your squad
yes this is the fantastic ripple effect
team and they deserve all the credit in
the world for creating this
great experience we've had so much fun
bringing back some of the most beloved
vehicles
gadgets weapons and maps from past
titles
well thank you all huge huge credit to
this amazing team and
everyone who's made battlefield 2042
possible all right so to bring it back
when you say
beloved maps we're talking caspian
border yes eureka harbor
yes el alamein yes el alamein is also
included it's actually my all-time
favorite map
plus we have no shark canal battle of
the bulge
and valparaiso and of course all
seven of the new epic scale maps already
announced for 2042
they're also playable in portal i love
it i love it but this is more than just
maps right
absolutely portal is a chance for the
community to drive the platform there's
a whole slate
of customization options and even an
advanced logic editor for you to play
around with
tools that were previously only
available to us on the development team
so that trailer it was just packed with
a ton of crazy moments
so i'm curious how wild can we actually
get with portal
you can get pretty wild yeah okay so can
i pit
world war ii against 2042 yes
okay okay uh what about game modes can i
make an
infection mode where it's me against a
ton of super fast soldiers with knives
absolutely okay uh what about shoddy
snipes but
but not just regular shoddy snipes like
like like a gun game with a whole bunch
of shoddy snipes from all throughout
history
that is a very specific idea there
austin but yes actually you can
baton three for three bring it home can
i play
as a penguin with a flamethrower a
penguin with a flamethrower yeah
no i mean look there are some limits
it's not a level editor you can't edit
the maps themselves
and no you can't play as a penguin with
a flamethrower all right that's that's
fine
it's fine i had to ask but it does sound
like there's a ton
to play around with oh yes the options
are pretty deep and we're committed to
working with the community
to build out this suite of tools and
content as the game evolves
we want this experience to go where you
want to take it
we see this sandbox as a big part of the
future of battlefield 2042
well i assume that the community is
going to have a field day with this
i really hope players will embrace
portal uh that's who we built it for
uh in fact we gave a sneak peek to a few
members of the community
to see what they could come up with oh
okay i assume my invitation got lost in
the mail but that's fine that's fine
let's check it out two teams and two
vips
but only one way to score this is vip
fiesta
by courage it's the u.s factions of
battlefield 3 and bad company 2
facing off on erica harbour with 24
players
and random loadouts die and you'll
redeploy with an all-new loadout
track down the enemy vip and make it
count
all bring the power of 2042 to caspian
border
and take on the forces of 1942 this
is quality versus quantity by gabitron
a small squad from 2042 are taking on 32
players from 1942
the future's got the hardware but the
past got the numbers
destroy those mcoms
but do it before your tickets are up
you're not getting them back
unless you clear the sector
not enough memes fine set up on orbital
for the fight of your lives
with robot man pirates acted
20 duck sized eod bots one horse-sized
t91
settle your battlefield debates on who
wins what
[Music]
come on dude robot man what this looks
so much
fun but i need to know just pretend like
the cameras aren't here just mean you
who's redacted can't tell you that sorry
but what i can tell you is that we're so
excited for the players
to create or simply discover their
favorite new way to play battlefield
and we can't wait to explore and try out
the thousands of experiences
our community will build once they have
the tools in their hands
and we get our hands on portal at launch
right yes porter will be available
at launch day one along with a bunch of
pre-made modes for you to try right away
okay this is this is fantastic now
christian before you go
let me make sure that i have all of this
straight so on top of all the content
and maps that have already been
announced
we also get content from battlefield
1942 bad company 2
and battlefield 3 including six of the
best maps of all time
and all that can be sliced diced and
mixed together in portal and then we
still have hazard zone coming later this
year
yes that's exactly what i'm telling you
austin if you've always been a fan or if
you've never played battlefield before
we want battlefield 2042 to be the
ultimate battlefield experience
christian just just thank you
thank you my pleasure austin i'll see
you on the battlefield
all right so portal looks incredible and
we could end things there
but i don't think we're done just yet
we're gonna leave you with one more
surprise first though you remember that
secret code
i hope you were paying attention because
all the letters have been revealed so
if you want to win some awesome games
and gear stick around because we're
gonna give you the link to enter in just
a second
but for now come with me
i hope you've enjoyed the show as much
as i've enjoyed being your host
now my name is austin creed and our last
reveal is somewhere
in there
but you know what why don't you go first
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh
uh
[Music]
you